she's promoted this Prosperity Gospel
stuff that you often hear from the
Christian preachers you can look at her
2012 book for examples of that she
sounds like Deepak Chopra half the time
with these unintelligible quotes that
are sort of like meant to sound profound
but they don't really mean anything just
one example is when she said everyone
feels on some level like an alien in
this world because we are we come from
another Realm Of Consciousness and long
for home
that just as easily could be a Deepak
Chopra quote another example Yin is
feminine Earth Yang is masculine Sky
when God is seen as he the soul is seen
as she just archetypes Spirit
impregnates soul
it's just not for me